the families of the victims of america's
gun epidemic have spoken already about
their pain their loss
but they were back on capitol hill this
time to listen to the people who make
the guns who had agreed for the first
time in 20 years to answer lawmakers
questions how many more american
children
need to die
before your company
will stop selling
assault weapons to civilians and
children the weapon of choice in most
mass murders in our country
congresswoman maloney i believe
that
these
murders are local problems
that have to be solved locally
it would seem that in america's gun
debate there isn't space for contrition
over several hours the familiar lines
were drawn you from your ivory tower in
dc you know better
we carry light arms and we own them
we own them legally we intend to keep
them
pro-gun republican lawmakers
head-to-head with the reformists on the
democratic side mr daniel this
advertisement appears to depict
premeditated violence or murder from a
rooftop
this is how the gun companies have made
over one billion dollars selling assault
rifles over the past decade
allowing their customers to believe they
can be soldiers
does this from daniel defense whose
ar-15 rifle was used in uvalde
and this
any rational person
can see the direct lines from this
marketing to the troubled young men who
kill people in places like buffalo and
el paso and uvalde
outside the hearing no comfort for the
families those are child they would do
it
they'll be moving mountains to get this
laws changed
honestly
these hearings are supposed to find
answers consensus to provoke change the
reality though so often seems to be that
they just expose the paralysis and the
polarization of politics here
the manufacturers and those politicians
who back them say it is the people not
their guns who are to blame mark stone
sky news in washington